Iow you know we have a son and. He lives in lismore and. Really. He's not really interested in this experiment at all.
He came here when he was sixteen and. He was too young to see any real benefit in it and too old to be to be.
To be formed by. My oldest daughter. The first time she was it was we were living in a tent.
And she came here and it was just a bare paddock.
There's no trees there wasn't a tree from that into this and you know. There are no trees at all.
She's told me years later i wonder what our other mother and dad going to do either.
However a few years after she came to live here. And that's nice. Family quiet time with.
Now having two family houses here. There's no reason. Son of the wanted to you could come and go to cabin on either.
Well you know. So that's good that's putting an experience for years probably being. I've done many things in my life.
In the jazz musician. Painter say human lives or you know all sorts of things. You know.
I think this is given me more interest than possibly any other thing in my life. Watching me. Developing and helping.
Yeah it's been a rewarding. Sort of experience and to see the village now. Just expanding.
I know that building down there. Is going to create activity and i know what happens when the pool. Grows so long as.
If the dream of that. Expansion. With all the right sort of ideal. States would they. And i'm sure you're ready.
For me. Bill includes all of us an economic experiment. Not something in the best sense.
It was an experiment in people's hearts. Everybody participated.
And so i still do regard this as a major change in my life of which i got an enormous benefit.
I've also pulled my hair out now and then and wonder why i was doing all this stuff. But. A major change in career.
From someone who was climbing to corporate and some other government letter.
Had to get on that path and actually started from nothing.
Being a free consultant to the whole village
and i was many needs from filling out forms to getting homeowners grants to dealing with councils and so on
and interest. But the benefits of that is just to give you an example. One.
I've started to go overseas consultancy work
and nine hundred eighty six in the been invited to in seychelles botswana india. Working.
Essential with communities which have the same legal structures we have multiple occupancies
or in some cases of course government departments to do with structures and. So changing.
A lot of thoughts into realities where are now exporting our systems we develop here. Out of poverty.
This whole place is to first. Sold our village in australia. It was built not by government brains.
It was built by poverty people couldn't afford anything else. And now we're exporting that knowledge.
See there's a major growth industry. So i could say at the end of ten years. Professionally as well as.
Emotionally again a lock. I don't think i can recommend a therapy i really believe that it's.
It's at has its deficits as well.
But certainly make me a healthier and stronger than i would have been in the city and. In terms of.
Family law i couldn't have been better than to tell you that a lot of the phone. Between living in a flat.
With the neighbors yelling. I'm fat and i can. Ambulances going by sound to a matter where.
And sitting in your own god given nature reserve and nothing but cook a beret and wallabies go on around and.
And your thing of course nurturing friendship. Media and in the. Ten years before it came to bill and cliff.
I didn't make one. Strong friend. I had acquaintances. I exchanged ideas.
I never lost my heart over anybody living here for ten years. I've developed. Beautiful friendships. Of a level.
I didn't think was possible really and. So that has been helpful. Benefit a q.r. I.q.
You know what the community means you know the person that is the sonne.
Quiet person that speaks only seldom yet of what you can burlai own.
You don't want to do you can go into a car for wonderful freedom to read to have a feeling of belonging to a village
where you want to race and not absolutely certain that are you two or three years duration.
Members said to me one day said. The most beautiful thing in my life. Is being allowed to be here.
To play in the growth of. It's the idea that it's good and something that. Your reward for others to see it happen.
As an economy. That i would put an equation to it. Because there is a direct relationship between work. None paid for.
Which is absurd. In society unless you're a volunteer worker here with the whole economy is based on that. Unpaid work.
And the payment for that is an emotional. Wealth and which is. You because you don't do it for yourself.
You do it for the community.
And somehow it comes back to you and it flows around
and it's something that conventional economists of directionless kind do not recognize.
Your doing this and somebody else is doing that yeah. There is old it looks like it's a movement of. All reality.
That in conventional economics is not being measured. It always has to be g.d.p.
and Output and growth and so on but we are talking about a different thing we're still about people
and they're talking about recycling some shitty. Economic system. And we're talking about recycling. People.
I give you a key example of what what just how how sound. The new economics is the definition of wealth.
Now you go to any conventional economist. Any government economist and wealth will be defined as. Assets and income.
And so wrong. Totally completely wrong that only defines half the energy of a single time.
Now if i can make a hundred dollars a day in one second and have the rest of the day to listen to the sum of birds.
I must by definition be wealthier than the guy who does the same hundred dollars in say twenty four hours.
So time is a real essence of. Of all of wealth in this economy here. And of course you cannot do it in isolation.
We are part of a system. But here. We recognize those hidden parts of the system.
And one of the things we've lost over the years right throughout the world. Is we have given our. Our neighborhood.
Sense our sense of community. Progressively over to how. Iran higher authorities. First from the church and.
Psychiatrist to state government a federal government united nations and ends of day.
And there's nothing wrong with that because we need strong central decision making obviously. But we shouldn't lose.
That sense of community. And that's how you play into trees. But telling your kids. If you plant that tree.
We look up to you be a good boy. You know. And he does it for free.
And he gets an emotional charge and love out of it and. I found the same thing here. Using years of.
Getting myself in the eight economic side. Into deeper and deeper financial trouble.
But into be economics or live like a king. I love it. Yes definitely a stand of the thing for quality of life.
We have to move away from a rigidly defined set.
That can see people in so-called third world countries being defined as being on the bottom of the poverty line.
Yet they've got a house. They've got an orchard got clean. They've got a wonderful.
Into a relationship but they don't have to cd player. Therefore to pour. Or they don't have a wage packet.
Because they work in the field deaf or décor it's a nonsense. If i would be a radical revolutionary.
But sometimes i wish i was. I would. I would really i would transform the whole the whole.
Nonsense of economics i would rip the guts out of economics teaching at universities.
And i would actually make income though that their. London school of economics has done mall.
To create the problems the world suffered from now than any other institution.
John i went to holland school of economics which is just like the one of them a top school.
And my school president who is now seventy nine years old from that time and we write regularly.
We discussed these things. How our entire profession. Has sold out to the dollar. How greed is the operative word.
Of the. Entire system.
I mean this is the man who i took a hit thirty years off of the european leadership team in business messages saying
the system doesn't work. We all know it isn't work.
So what we could have to do is we're going to have to empower the lifestyle i would like to see the harm in falling
into dirt farming.
I'd like to people to wake up at night i'm a freak of the morning
and ask him what would you like to do that say not to plant a tree a lock to grow my own vote.
No more dense and they're saying. I want that new cd player. You know. You don't need it. When are we on a sly.
Aid society generally all across the face of the earth. I feel is on a very slippery slide down. You know you know.
Of a lever it's like a horse ride you've lost the reins your feet are out of the stirrups you galloping headlong. Down.
I think. When we get to the bottom of whatever this steep slope happens to be. I think places like will and curse.
Will be there for the reconstruction. It would seem we're going from strength to strength of the system.
As having a hard another time here. So you say well.
Because we may this particular place may not survive because it could. If that.
Crunch comes this could be just hours or ron. You know we could all be dead you know that it's places like this.
That will survive where your soil is be nurtured. And food will grow. It's not easy to grow. If you were you without.
Chemicals. And how. How can it be easy when you land has been ruined. Yet when you teach your kids.
You know indigenous language. You don't cut them into the indigenous knowledge of plant life.
To take land in a lack of leach are you.
You're not you're not taking your kids out and actually show them how to plant. Of food.
I mean this should be standard thing or in the curriculum. Sure they should. Are they should absolutely.
Without that you're not going to be your own members and as you'll get all the english. Guy here today.
Steven lisa tell you it's all yours guys in my are a.j. and. The jazz face. You know we were brought up.
Within probably thirty miles of each other it was weird. However.
How much more do you want here and i want to say one thing the. Chance you say it while you're thinking of it and that.
When i hear. John talking about the system collapsing and it's a reality in our minds that it could happen.
Certainly do. The indicators i'm very good.
I sometimes wish that we'd have more government cooperation that if you're really.
I'd love to work with governments on a year or two to actually. Do these things on a large scale i mean.
You can spend ten years of your life.
Proving something that everybody knows which is that you get healthier when you plant your own garden.
You can get a happier if you have good friends. Let's now. Let's not take this incredible discovery. Into camera.
And that is actually saying that's let's do it. You know. Let's do it get away. Nifty let's take these people.
And that's and let's give them something you. You could do is heaps of land. Which is misused.
That can be really lovely that can be brought in you will go in you know. You want to say something. Yes where you are.
Giveaways on the you just grab a bunch of flies around with you know school. Going to ask you a question.
Verse so we can say one more thing. I don't know what strikes you is the main thing. You're outside.
You can see some of it and we can. Hear about bill. It's different when you're on one side. But you know. And i work.
With him yet. How will you know your timetable is very complicated.
If the father has all of the models all the good side countable. The dominant and. Buddy. They're really nice.
You know they're really dives. But it's. It's that. The religious trip. You know you couldn't do that. Buddy.
Trip with one hundred fifteen people like we did. When we had a guy. In our living body farm.
After ten years living here didn't get anything for his house because it belongs to the commune.
And the effort can start again it's very difficult to do that. It's an unrealistic model as a monist three.
Car right here. Yep or religious retreat. Right and then we need does place. We do. But as a model for the massive.
Resettlement that's got to take place. It doesn't work.
So we could get into trouble knowing god we're not rival you know we cannot be no matter how much we would all like to
be. We are not. That's why we call our meeting a residence meeting. Tangible cause as a tribal me where you say.
We understand that tribalism. Is for tribal people. And even. Having trouble living. Tribally. Nowadays. So this is.
There are going to be others. There are going to be others. That will come along. Which will be different.
I see it happening in the suburbs i really do not see. What would stop.
Well directed government programs into the suburbs into small towns that in essence.
Are taking and employ people and supporting mothers and certain pensions like that
and make them contribute to society i really believe. After ten years of living here.
In what something new described as so security has been our kind. To so security system.
Undermining more than a does good. I'm not saying you can just change it and take it away.
That is not enough another thing i'm saying you should direct it in a more meaningful way. More than saying to mr i.
Here is your money. Do as you please you are a free individual. That is your bread. You can drink it.
You can gamble it you can do what you want to.
That's for you to live on what it misses is again a part of the equation that money. Must flow back into society.
And therefore i think it should come tied. If you live in a community.
Your breathe the same air your walk on the sidewalk. You.
You get the protection of a friend news of a deaf we should contribute to it. Well you know those little schemes.
There are some around where zoe lived in red hill in brisbane opposite.
There were six houses and they were owned by a co-operative. And you got it for a very small amount of money.
But you didn't you never did like if you lived that he's sorry. See you later. Argue that it is raining.
And united behind that that got to the culture of god
and a massive culture gotten went right down the back of the whole of the six houses.
They were virtually fluid free you know it can be done. It can be done but i believe what is required now.
Is that government takes up one of the mentors. Step. And applies. See the e.p.a.
Which is commune development employment program to adult to adult. Not as an exclusive measure.
No as a new measure that you are allowed to settle a bit of land where you don't get the money directly your.
Residents get it.
And that has a management structure like we've got here and it says ok you get your money
but you were forty hours a week. Doing office work to do in the ukraine employment in this book.
To the money is there already.
It's a nonsense to ask someone here saying go look for a job because right now a job in five hundred miles.
Even if you try. Not if you did do would be five thousand people before the owner and when it was too early.
So what you should do is saying. As john said earlier. The system. Doesn't recognize the real work.
Therefore that the money flow into the village. Therefore. Let the village and. Employ people as artists as.
Guest people as pothole or whatever you have and. Then you have a locally based economy. Same money.
Same exercise c.d.p. Cost twenty percent more than the dull cost it's a very wise investment.
It would change the landscape. Of australia overnight in terms of people's perception of how to tackle the future.
I think the biggest problem i have today.
Is that i don't see that sense doing this in a sense we haven't just discussion.
I don't see that reflected to a national level. And i don't see it as being. Environmental matters.
Just being used as a bloody football you know they grab it if they think it's a few votes in the eye knock it down if
they think there's a few votes that way you know. However. We're rapidly coming to the stage where.
Something is going to have to be done. When we can no longer walk outside the front door in daylight hours.
People will start to get water. You know i don't think people don't really want to be trouble or die.
You know what we're going to have to be you know a bloody reflective salute you know..
Sometimes i wonder we were now living in a day and age where you are being peddled. U.v. Shielding clothing is.
Slip on a hat put on fifteen plus and you go outside. And then you're saying.
Well the air pollution problem is not really that bad just yet we have a factor of three point two leaders i mean.
At what point do we say you know. Well look it's even crazier. A place like this which was a model.
In an area which acts like a model and one of the many areas around the world is in fact being discriminated.
To the point it has a hard time sustaining itself. We still have state government. In effect. While undermining.
Essential parts of our local economy. Because it doesn't recognize it. Just yet. I mean.
At this day and age it's crazy. As one of them.
When you learn to use one of them it would also go with waste disposal toxic algae. It goes with. State system.
Dispersion of grants. And so on. I found over the years to government.
We always assume too much brains in the government. You know we. Big big government is a system.
And the flow of money like an ab. And if we're coming back in for the tide of taxation.
We've got several hundred million a billion years going into the treasury converse.
And then in texas reimbursement comes out again and.
Goes back and forth in government in people that is a very moron a process very slow to change.
So you'll find that there is established ways of getting money into the community.
We pay our farmers at c s r o for research we support our rule industry we want to put some money into the sugar
industry want to support our dollar dependence. We want to get people's.
Legal things sort of money goes back and forth. As our soul says. This is how we want to change society.
Now what has had to happen is we're going to have to take this. I've been. All money. And redirected completely.
We're going to have to get a lot of the things that are. Earth negative. And put it into things. Of earth positive.
And it's a very simple process that just means. Not put into petro and the chemical companies first.
And allow one farmer to go broke for a million bucks to the bank.
On a bit of land that he's poisoning and a soul goes into melbourne into the air.
You know we have to get a thousand people working with their hands. And there are still people in government saying.
You can't get away with that though unless of course you want to do it.
Because they don't know what you don't put a barrier there saying that land going to cost you fifty thousand bucks.
You know. It's going back to the land that's what all it was all about the twenty first century to me.
It's going to be mushy mcluhan's global village.
And you can now live on the land with a fax machine and you can work a solo in brothers in new york.
You don't have to live in a city anymore. You know. And therefore we can get away from the dichotomy between.
The city and the rural land.
And we actually can saying people are merging in and become the caretaker society where we believe that the third why.
That toffler right about. Is actually. It started you know.
Industrialised nation is dead it's just going to take a while for it. Wake up to that fact and lay down and get buried.
But industrialized nation is finished and the new tribe or the new. Village. Is there. Works and space.
It's a many people got. We've all got telephones you know it. Couple of years ago.
Before we got our strata tight we couldn't afford to if they wanted eighteen hundred dollars to put one in the running
man. We said as we got the strada. Four hundred dollars. You know. And it was ridiculous isn't it. We got.
We've got a system of government now. That allows us to get money from the taxpayer. To drive. A car. Built in japan.
With oil. Harvested in saudi arabia. To buy the vegetables. Grown either ipswich or in thailand.
And we were wondering why report that record because we don't make our own cups.
We all make our own shirts we don't we don't grow our own foods. And the essence to me.
The answers are here it's just that. This is only a microcosm.
Does not have to be translate this whole valley here when you go back to lose more.
As you just get down off the hill on to the flats down there.
Those flats in the thirty's used to provide sydney and melbourne with onions and christ knows what else. To mana. Yeah.
There's nothing there now that. Cloven hoofed down trodden bloody attics. That.
You look at it it's a senate bill strip. They desperately need it. And we need.
If we're going to repair the hours arm by using the oxygen then it should be against the world law for anybody else to
cut down the solitary bloody tree unless it's a pine tree or slash park in tree because they're the only thing.
Trees that don't do and use you. And the real obscenity is not even.
The moron who cuts down that tree on the on the slope. Because you want to get more grass to his cow.
The real obscenity is debt. Our whole system pays for that knowledge and actually obstruct the opposite yes.
Because the power has been flowing into exactly that group. And so you're getting a situation where literally.
Your assets are being stripped day in day out. On taxpayers' money. Still today.
Well a tree today you know to go and buy a tree today. Of the forestry. Cus you about twenty five bucks.
Is a tree is being growing for something like seventy bloody year. It's true value should be ran.
Three or four hundred bucks. John if i would be in charge of the prime minister's department one day.
I would do the following. I would say this land is worth so much. After you rip the trays out the.
Erode the soil after thirty years it's worth that much will cost that much to really have been a tight and.
For this is your taxation vice. Just like in china they'll say you have your second cube.
You'll you actually go down a living standard.
So it's not fair to allow a man to sell a cow for three for one of bucks.
When in fact the taxpayer ten years from now must rehabilitate atlanta. Because he didn't own that soil.
He just and this is very important ownership all you own is the rights to can't take an income but. A bit of land.
During your life. All right and if you don't have some. Some clothes you can give your kid.
So be it or be some other thing but you don't own the land you don't own soil that is owned by the government.
All the minerals and data on what the government of arizona the government the only had the right to use.
And therefore conventional economics betrays the future generation. Because it says. Rick rick rick rick rick rip.
Pretty my own pocket. And off i go to england or whatever i want in my when roz kelly. Snatch back this.
Training package for primary school. That said. It told the truth. Than our current practices are destroying the earth.
And the farming lobby is so bloody strong in this country that that thing was ready to go out to the schools.
And they got it stopped. I find it scandalous i don't want the truth. To be known.
But i think most young children today. Know what's going on.
I think the primary school teachers are doing a tremendous job with regards to the environment problems.
I don't know whether that's having any effect on the way kids behave with little.
And all that because i don't have kids around here are generally. Pretty good. Because if any adult.
Sees a child drop a piece of litter. They say that up. Thank you very much indeed a thanks or.
Would you like a cup of tea.